he is the oscar-winning filmmaker whose
hit movie Bowling for Columbine makes
its 20th anniversary this year and he's
the host of the podcast rumbled with
Michael Moore my good friend Michael
Moore
Michael Moore
Mike
no
how are you you look great you look like
Michael Les
I am feeling pretty good actually I've
uh yeah I think the pandemic
trying to take care of myself yeah you
look great I see you're in your bunker
there with the map uh you're
undisclosed location and uh
so listen uh we've talked about the
midterms many times here I I think
there's a sort of a bright spot there in
the fact that the country is on the
brink of disaster which for the first
time I can remember the midterms are
sexy this is the one usually we had
trouble getting people to go out and
vote for but now there's very high
enthusiasm for a midterm election so
what what do you think is going to
happen
um well so just before I say what I
think is going to happen I need to
preface it by telling everybody who's
watching that
um everybody needs to show up and you
need to bring five to ten people with
you on Election Day that is incredible
that's a lot of people but make it you
know bring beer make it a fun thing have
a party afterwards whatever but I
honestly believe Bill and you know you
and I are are two well-known uh
pessimists I think and and I have never
felt this optimistic and I and you know
I was on your show here
um well it's now six years ago
when I said that Trump was going to win
and uh the audience booed me and you
stood up for me
um I was just saying when I look I'm out
I'm around I you know I'm from the
Midwest I think I had a pretty good
sense of what was going to happen I
think the opposite's going to happen
this time I think that that there is
going to be
such a landslide against the Traders
especially the 147 Republicans who just
hours after the Insurrection voted to
not certify the elected president of the
United States Joe Biden and I think that
there is going to be so many people
coming out to vote I want to thank the
Supreme Court for reminding women that
they are in fact second-class citizens
and and taking their rights away like
this there are so many I don't know if
you've seen the list of states starting
with Kansas which by the way 60 of the
people in Kansas a couple months ago
showed up to say no we want abortion
legal and we want it in our constitution
we want to stay there and this is I
think that there's going to be such a
massive printout of women uh 70 of all
new registered voters in Kansas for
women uh in Wisconsin it's 17 more than
men are registering to vote uh
Pennsylvania 12 I mean in most of these
states women who have these are women
who have not voted who've not been
registered are coming out to register
and then look what happened in Alaska
Alaska only gets one member of Congress
and elects a woman a Native Alaskan
woman
to defeat Sarah Palin Alaska
this is like there are so many signs of
this that I think I honestly think if we
all do our work and if we all get people
to get out there and we get out there
ourselves we have a chance uh to do
something that it does happen every now
and then 1993 Canada uh voted every
conservative member in Parliament except
for two out of office gone
all of them except for two and then four
years later in the Great Britain 1997
uh the every conservative member of the
British Parliament
in Scotland in Wales and from Northern
Ireland were all thrown out of office I
think we can throw out a huge number of
these Republican Traders uh in November
November 8th